[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous montez souvent vous
allez dites le moi
au pire vous mentir et c'est pas grave
hein
vous savez je parle de ces ces petits
mensonges du quotidien par exemple vous
êtes à la machine à café vous avez un de
vos collègues qui vient vous voir et qui
vous dit ça va et vous vous lui répondez
quoi
bah oui en fait vous avez enterrer votre
grand père il ya deux jours on ça va pas
super bien et puis vous savez il ya
cette image de vacances absolument
idyllique que vous postez sur les
réseaux sociaux avec cette petite
légende juste un bal qui dit vacances de
rêve
sauf que ce que vous oubliez de dire
c'est qu'il vous a fallu trois heures
pour prendre cette photo entre vos
enfants qui se mettaient un peu sur la
tronche en faisant des pâtés de sable
votre mari qui vous demandait de le
prendre en photo des qui faisait un
plongeon est un peu pénible quand même
cette affaire bref c'était pas trop les
vacances idylliques mais pourquoi mentir
en fait pourquoi pour se sentir mieux
pour avoir l'impression d'exister
d'avoir une vie inédite
en fait elle est inédite votre vie
puisque c'est la vôtre et parfois mentir
ça un petit peu plus loin ouais parfois
on peut mentir pour se faire élire
ouais
cet homme donald trump et l'amendé n'est
pas qu'un peu en même temps il fait rien
à moitié on sort l'a bien compris par
donald trump
il a menti parce que figurez-vous que
politique fact un institut de
vérification des informations
américaines a stipulé que seuls 4% des
propos de donald trump pendant la
campagne électorale et eve rail 4%
non mais vous imaginez autrement dit
rien on est d'accord cette campagne ça a
été qu'un tissu de mensonges
malgré l'opiniâtreté répéter un de
nombreux médias américains a essayé de
trouver tous les jours un peu plus le
contraire ouais là est élu qu'est ce qui
fait qu'on laisse agir un menteur en
sachant qu'il m'en faut être un peu
banon vous avez une idée maintenant va
peut-être parce que finalement au mans
tous un peu parfois pourtant souvent
comme cette photo de vacances finalement
qui n'était pas vraiment aidé ilic ou
comme bas se savent à qui globalement
n'en était pas un on est bien d'accord
alors bas pour qui est aussi mensonge il
faut des menteurs je vous ai préparé une
petite galerie de mon top five on y va
alors le premier vous le connaissez tous
évidemment bon c'est un amateur parce
que lui sait repérer tout de suite c'est
quand même si nos chiodin compris
qu'avec son nez ça allait pas très très
loin mais le deuxième c'est mon préféré
bah ouais c'est romain gary à romain
gary
brillantissime mythifie catr de sa
propre vie mais pour le bonheur de la
littérature française et puis aussi pour
le meilleur
j'adore romain gary on y reviendra et
puis on a un autre que vous connaissez
bien si c'est lance amstrong arrêts
alors lui lance bas il a troqué la pompe
à vélo pour la pompe a eu pète ça allait
un peu plus vite et s'est fait prendre
et puis m'a écouté le dernier c'est un
peu le m lemaitre en france comment j'ai
nommé monsieur jérôme cahuzac or bah oui
quand même bien sûr alors jérôme cahuzac
ce qui est assez drôle c'est que c'est
un peu comme un acteur de cinéma c'est à
dire que lui il a décidé de troquer le
t'as de beaux yeux tu sais pour le et
les yeux dans les yeux
moi j'en ai pas les comptes en suisse
non non non rien 1
et puis après il ya un maintien
en fait il ya moi ouais ouais c'est vrai
que ça que c'est une sacrée menteuse en
fait je l'était jeu l'était jusqu'à
temps que je m'aperçoive que ça ça me
devenait insupportable en fait de mentir
ouais vraiment insupportable parce que
en fait je me sens responsable de la
part de vérité que je mets tous les
jours dans le monde à dos moi j'avais un
rêve
on en a tous mais là c'était le mien
je voulais être journaliste et puis mon
père m'avait dit tous de clèves la fin
vous n'avez pas compris
difficile à traduire peut-être en fait
c'est un accent portugais parce que je
suis fille d'immigrés portugais
donc mon père me disait tous du club la
fin assez bon je pense que des fois vous
avez compris et en fait on avait des
discussions comme ça tous les deux alors
moi j'avais ce rêve d'être journaliste
et puis du baril avaient le rêve que je
sois à l'abri du besoin
même s'il fallait faire taire mes envies
donc je disais mais papa regarde le
monde est en train de changer je veux je
vais le raconter je veux témoigner je
vais aller sur les terrains là deux
clubs la fin mais papa écoute
mandela a été libéré le mur de berlin
vient de tomber desclèves la fin parfois
je m'en prenais pas de chance qu'ils
disaient et puis je me souviens aussi un
peu plus petit du démarrage du jt de 20h
d'entendre égrainé les jours de
détention des journalistes otages
retenus au liban pour la liberté
d'informer avec un souci de vérité et
moi je rêvais modestement de pouvoir
emprunter leurs traces avec cette phrase
de camus que j'aime beaucoup qui dit la
liberté et la vérité sont des maîtresses
exigeante parce qu'elles n'ont que peu
d'âme en la liberté et la vérité sont
des maîtresses exigeante parce qu'elles
n'ont que peu d'âme en conclusion a pas
simple d'être libre ça on a compris mais
alors pas simple d'être dans le noir non
plus hein et puis bah quand on a un père
comme moi qui a fui clandestinement son
pays pour des raisons politiques pas je
vous cache pas que au move to pas
offusqué bah ouais ouais on fait ce
qu'il dit c'est pénible et rêve en fait
un ouais surtout quand on les réalise
pas alors on préfère les oublier
et puis on s'oublie un peu avec et on
commence par se mentir par omission par
omission de soi ça c'est mon premier
mensonge le journalisme c'est pas pour
moi pas alors qu'est ce que je fais
comme papa voulait une école de commerce
c'est pour tous les échelons et on peut
les écoles de commerce à certains sont
peut-être connu donc j'ai fait une école
de commerce et me voilà embarquée sur la
petite autoroutes du mensonge dans une
rutilante carrière marketing alors là
des bois prestigieux l'acv brillant un
clinquant non c'était extrêmement
brillant brillant dehors mais alors
dedans ça menthe est sacrément mais papa
aimant bon il était fier qu'est-ce
qu'ils étaient fiers
bah oui il fallait bien que je monte
dans l'ascenseur social mois la fille
d'immigrés mais petite confidence
vous êtes déjà resté dix ans dans un
ascenseur même sociale
je peux vous dire c'est vrai c'est
vraiment très très très long pour suivre
ar c'est marrant parce que il ya
plusieurs types de mensonges il ya le
mensonge par protection chérie je t'ai
tromper mais je peux pas te le dire ça
va te faire trop de mal
il ya le mensonge par omission le fameux
g en fait je vais te dire que j'ai bu ni
la voiture il ya le mensonge par
manipulation suit larry et hop tu sais
que ce sprint va hyper bien et puis elle
mensonge par résignation le marketing
dans les grandes boîtes
c'est pour moi je convaincs content
tiens à propos de marketing
est-ce que parmi vous certains achètent
vous avez les produits dans les
supermarchés avec le label élu produit
de l'année y en a ou pas levé la main
peut dénoncer vous dénoncez vous
tradition française dénoncent haut à
main vous savez comment ça marche ou pas
non je vous expliquais est ce que vous
pensez qu'en fait ces produits reçoivent
ce label parce qu'ils sont ils ont une
empreinte carbone limité parce qu'ils
sont bons pour la santé ou parce que
vraiment c'est des produits top en
france tous à extraire un truc génial
ah non non non en fait ils ont ce label
parce que hein parce que le packaging
est hyper chouette ça on adore les pas
caché ça c'est génial en petite boîte
remâchant sa rente c'est super le
packaging et puis le nom du produit sa
couleur bref tout le reste
bah c'est ça un peu le marketing en fait
parfois parfois et ben moi ça a commencé
à me gêner véritablement et c'est à ce
moment là que romain gary le dit est ce
que moi romain gary me parle
bah ouais romain gary me dit mais elle
ça mais la vérité c'est ne pas se faire
prendre
droit trop tard ou trop tard bah ouais
moi j'étais empêtré dans le mensonge
à croire que ce genre de métier c'était
ce vers quoi j'avais véritablement envie
d'aller ouais et en plus ça commençait à
voir physiquement nausées vomissements
j'étais enceinte nausées vomissements
crise de panique tétanie insomnies
colère mais grosse colère alors contre
le monde en tire véritablement et puis
en fait sont mes enfants qui m'ont
reconnecter à la vérité à la mienne qui
m'ont invité à ne plus être dans ce
sentiment d'imposture pour aller
toujours plus loin avec et massue mais
avec toutes mes failles alors au bout de
dix ans bat le marketing et moi on se
dit que finalement on s'aimait pas
vraiment il était donc on se dit que ce
mariage de raison
devait cesser alors danser quittés bons
amis en c1
on s'est un tout petit peu écharpe sur
les la gare des indemnités de
licenciement pas grand chose
vraiment quelques mois mais maintenant
que faire bah oui mais j'avais pu 36000
option pour être honnête ans et c'est
pas de la flagornerie que je le veux
dire donc j'ai monté une boîte j'ai
monté un site communautaire où les
jeunes parents pouvaient venir
s'exprimer en toute sincérité sur l'
expérience de consommation
et ça ça ça a été le début de ma
révolution à moi vraiment et il n'y a
pas de jennifer dans l'histoire ça a été
le début de la révolution en fait ça va
même beaucoup plus loin parce que cette
société ça a été comme la météorite qui
vient vous dévié de la trajectoire dans
laquelle vous n'étiez pas vraiment à
l'aise parce que pour présenter cette
société je suis allé sur un plateau de
télé en tant qu'invité et je suis
reparti comme chroniqueuse et ça
ça a duré très longtemps au bout de
trois ans passés on me dit mais ça y est
ça y était enfin journalistes depuis le
temps que tu ne vous plaît toujours à
l'isthme d'ailleurs agi ben non non non
vous commencez à me connaître maintenant
ce sentiment d'imposture toujours
j'avais pas le diplôme
j'étais pas journaliste qu'à cela ne
tienne je sais pas si certaines ou
certains d'entre vous lisent les
magazines féminins mais on dit que 40
ans est de nouveau 20 ans alors moi
aussi je me suis dit que c'était ça et
me voilà repartie sur les bancs de
l'école supérieure de journalisme de
paris et ce qui est assez drôle c'est
que j'ai eu mon diplôme
le lendemain de l'élection de donald
trump dingue droit même assez marrant
parce que moi les dates jcrois vachement
a toujours dessiné avec les dates et
pour moi cette date là était vraiment
importante parce que c'était le signe
que mon métier
le métier de journalisme de journalistes
il devait clairement changé évolué dans
ses pratiques il avait été tellement mis
en défiance lors de cette élection
alors pour contrecarrer les mensonges
victorieux de l'homme à la mèche
je me suis dit que j'avais une
responsabilité qui était celle
d'informer les français en toute
objectivité sur le choix de leurs
candidats pour leur élection
présidentielle a eu alors j'ai monté un
site qui répertoriait qui comparait les
onze programmes des candidats aux
élections présidentielles avec l'aide
précieuse d'un ami et ce site
c'était un site citoyen bénévole
gratuit sans financement ville de coude
vraiment aussi un peu de jus de cerveau
et nous avons lancé ce site alors ce cas
c'est marrant c'est que je suis allé
voir mais selon duly confrères du métier
journaliste et puis des gens carte
payante directeur de rédaction
pour vraiment dérangeant ancien reporter
de guerre directeur de publication des
gens hyper capés qui m'impressionnait
beaucoup et je leur ai dit voilà je vais
monter ce site je cherchais un peu
d'être ce que seul c'était quand même
pas une mince affaire
vous savez pas s'il m'a répondu mais
elle ça tu vas quand même pas liées aux
programmes des folles enfin ben c'est
pas un peu notre métier bon ben on est
débutant bon
à sac la vérité elle est un peu
exigeante et demande un peu de boulot
quand même ans donc c'est pas toujours
très très simple et ben ouais ouais
ouais j'ai lu les onze pros grave je
vous cache pas que pour certains c'était
la purge
en tout cas c'est comme ça que moi je
conçois mon métier aujourd'hui est en
fait vous savez ce qui s'est passé plus
d'un demi million de comparaison de
programmes ont été effectués sur ce site
moi j'en était bouleversée de voir cet
engouement et je vous passe les messages
de remerciements merci maintenant je
sais pour qui je vais voter
objectivement j'ai été éclairés sur
telle thématique je sais ce qui se passe
sur tel programme
c'est vraiment différent ce que je peux
voir ailleurs assez avec la vérité l
exigeante mais qu'est ce qu'elle est
reconnaissante et c'est mon métier de
journaliste aujourd'hui qui me permet de
vous le dire en tout cas la façon dont
moi je le conçois qui est celle de vous
questionner de vous interroger de parler
des trains qui arrivent à l'heure de nos
folles ressources pour changer un peu le
monde aussi parce qu'on est tous
capables et vous savez alors oui ouais
c'est vrai que ce site il a été
extrêmement porteur pour moi et que
finalement le monde il est pas blanc ou
noir
il a 7 milliards 7 milliards de nuances
par exemple le marketing c'est par
mauvaise outil c'est plutôt la façon
dont on le travail qui peut être
contestable
utilisez une étude de marché pour
prouver que son produit peut être
amélioré pour le consommateur c'est
plutôt une bonne idée
on est d'accord en revanche quand il
s'agit d'utiliser une étude de marché
pour montrer que son produit est sain
alors que d'autres études impartiale
disent qu'il ne l'est pas sartre c'est
condamnable
monsieur monsanto avec votre glyphosate
ça ça l'est vous voyez comme le mensonge
à un pouvoir
mais la vérité en a bien davantage
j'ai un dernier exemple après je vous
laisse tranquille
a pas très longtemps j'ai animé une
conférence sur la déficience
intellectuelle lourd sujet des experts
expliqué qu'on ne faisait pas assez
attention à la parole des déficients
intellectuels qu'on ne voyait pas que le
regard de l'autre pouvait être
extrêmement pénalisant et cetera tous à
grand renfort de blabla et blabla et
puis une question à fuser dans le public
question qui a dit vous parlez de
redonner la parole aux déficients
intellectuels mais où sont-ils sur votre
estrades
ça faisait trois heures on parlait alors
j'ai demandé à julien 32 ans à qui le
chromosome 13 à jouer un vilain tour à
la naissance de venir nous rejoindre sur
la scène et je lui ai demandé simplement
jeudi m qu'est-ce que tu retiens de tout
ce qu'on vient de se dire et dans sa
vérité à lui il m'a dit maintenant quand
quelqu'un me demandera ce qu'est un
handicap et je pourrais lui répondre en
trois minutes
il a mis tout le monde d'accord avec sa
vérité ali alors oui c'est vrai je suis
certainement pas la journaliste que
j'aurais été si je l'avais été ya vingt
ans et c'est en cela aussi que je
remercie mon père vraiment je peux lui
en vouloir
mais je peux aussi lui dire merci mais
ça ma mère j'ai envie d'adresser un
petit message aussi aujourd'hui a pas
très longtemps ma mère m'a dit
j'aimerais tellement être toi
ma chère maman sans toi je ne le serai
pas c'est toi qui m'as appris à n'en
faire qu'à mon coeur j'ai mis un tout
petit peu de temps pour le comprendre
alors c'est vrai que rennes est facile
hein surtout pas se poser au
déterminisme familiale surtout pas les
chemins tracés
rien n'est simple mais n'oubliez pas la
vérité elle a un pouvoir immense immense
celui de nous émerveiller de nous
découvrir de nous questionner de nous
apprivoiser aussi et surtout surtout
celui de nous réveiller mois en arrêtant
de mentir je sais aujourd'hui que je
suis responsable de la part de vérité
que je mets dans le monde
et vous quelle part de vérité
vous êtes prêt à mettre dans le monde
maintenant
[Applaudissements]